[Music]
innovation story depth combat were lead
quests nostalgia these are all factors
that will contribute to the showdown of
the decade between two giants of gaming
history The Legend of Zelda breath of
the wild versus the legend of zelda
ocarina of time it's time to take apart
piece by piece these two fundamental
gaming achievements and pit them against
each other in a legendary battle that
has been on the minds of every Zelda fan
since the release of the newest
installment now obviously the game that
has 20 years of newer technology and
experience under its belt is gonna have
some major advantages such as visual
appearance
so therefore subjects like this one are
not going to be points of argument
however world size and number of quests
while still technically related to
hardware will be used as points of
argument even though it poses as a
disadvantage to the older game so now
let us begin the gaming showdown of the
century argument one the reviews as with
any new release along with hordes of
adoring fans comes hordes of adoring
reviews this point is going to be pretty
darn close because both games have
received nearly perfect scores across
the board
starting with ocarina of time overall
the game received a 98.5% perfect score
that's 98 out of 100 from Game Rankings
and 99 out of 100 from Metacritic which
was based off of 11 other reviews from
the following 5 out of 5 stars from all
game 10 out of 10 from edge 10 out of 10
from egm 40 out of 40 from Famitsu 5 out
of 5 stars from game Pro and a from game
revolution 10 out of 10 from GameSpot 10
out of 10 from game trailers 10 out of
10 from IGN 9.5 from Nintendo Power and
5.5 from RPG gamer
now onto breath of the wild the game has
so far received a 96.5% perfect rating
overall from Metacritic with a 97 out of
100 being rated for the switch version
and 96 out of 100 for the Wii U based
off of the following 15 reviews 10 out
of 10 from Destructoid 10 out of 10 from
head
nine point five out of ten from egn five
out of five stars from Eurogamer 40 out
of 40 from Famitsu 10 out of 10 from
Game Informer five out of five stars
from game revolution 10 out of 10 from
gamespot five out of five stars from
GamesRadar five out of five from giant
bomb 10 out of 10 from IGN 10 out of 10
stars from Nintendo life 9.5 out of 10
from Nintendo World Report 10 out of 10
from polygon and 9 out of 10 from
videogame or calm based off these
numbers alone the average of both games
comes out to Ocarina of Time being on
top with a 98.5 out of 100 being greater
than 96.5 at 100 for breadth of the wild
even though breadth of the while it has
had more reviews 15 as opposed to 11
that possibly lead to a slight
disadvantage with it receiving a total
of three subjects cores as opposed to
Ocarina of times only one sub perfect
score this point still goes to Ocarina
of Time because both have received an
aggregate score from the same company
Metacritic ocarina of time receiving as
before-mentioned a 99 out of 100 and
breadth of the wild receiving a 97 out
of 100 for the switch version coming
down to a difference of literally two
percent Ocarina of Time takes home this
first point argument to the combat the
combat systems between the two games are
very similar ocarina of time created the
lockon z-targeting system that every 3d
Zelda game has copied so far because
quite frankly it's a genius system
breath of the wild however further
expounded upon the targeting system by
adding in motion controls but not those
swing your we mowed around like a maniac
kind instead the motion controls work
along with analog controls seamlessly
when aiming to either fire an arrow or
chuck a weapon at an enemy also a new
feature to breath in the wild by the way
you can actually use the analog stick to
turn your camera large distances and
then physically move your controller to
zero in to make the perfect shot and
additionally you can actually disable
the motion controlled aiming system if
it ever annoys you breath of the wild
also added the weapon durability
mechanic that forces you to constantly
switch weapons or
an enemy for double damage many see this
as a bad thing I say to them get over it
I think it adds a great survival in
strategy aspect to every fight even
against puny red pecans ocarina of time
just didn't have the vast weaponry or
accelerated targeting systems that
breath of the wild features therefore
breath of the wild claims the second
point argument three story be warned
here be spoilers seriously good the link
on the screen to skip ahead to spoiler
free waters in point four I'll give you
a few moments to do that okay we have
been warned ocarina of time story was
fantastic breath of the wilds backstory
because that's what it is the whole time
link spends the whole game discovering
should you choose to the story of what
happened via his memories of a hundred
years past was phenomenal so comparing
the two is again rather difficult
because they each have such different
styles of storytelling the average
player finishes the game and effectively
the story in ocarina of time the first
playthrough in about 40 hours of
gameplay while in breadth of the while
it's completely dependent on what you
the player decide to do if you decide to
figure out everything that happened in
the past you can do so at your own pace
I would say though that a person
progressing normally through breadth of
the wild the first time would finish up
the memory portion at around 40 hours of
gameplay as well or at least that was my
personal time finishing them from my
personal experience and browsing the web
thoroughly on this topic I believe I can
safely say that the story of breath of
the wild while amazing is lacking and
the way that it grips you this is due to
the very fact that it is open world and
it is nonlinear test the initial
tutorial of course and everything is
optional the nature of an optional story
alone lessens impact that is just a fact
I actually made a controversial video
about how I was afraid that exactly this
would happen with the story due to open
world 'no switch I will link right here
anyways on the other hand ocarina of
time story gripped the player's emotions
much more effectively I believe because
you actually play through the events and
watch it happen
you I remember the first time I figured
out Ganondorf just used by claiming the
Master Sword and opening the door to the
sacred ground as the major pawn and his
plan of evilness and I remember the
emotions that ran through my head heart
and hands as I gripped that controller
and thought to myself wow this is
something I did this is something I need
to fix Ganondorf will fall by my hand
and breath of the wild
I don't remember feeling emotions this
strong towards the characters any of
them to be honest true there were strong
elements of fear failure and hope but
there were all just videos you watched
about what you did a hundred years ago
none of it changed your current purpose
your current abilities or your mindset
but rather gave you further
understanding of your situation I could
go on and on about the comparison of
impact of the story between the two and
if I feel like I have to make a separate
video about each of these I will but for
now what these points I've made the
third one goes to Ocarina of Time
argument for quests this one let's face
it is super obvious which game has more
quests rather the wild which game has
more rewards from quests the wild which
game has more diversified quests but
Mass Nintendo bandit Ocarina of Time has
sneaking quests so does breadth of the
wild Ocarina of Time has farming quests
so does breadth of the wild Ocarina of
Time has horse quests so does breadth of
the wild literally with the exception of
a few quests that Ocarina of Time may
just have done better it comes down to
which game has more not including
dungeons of course this goes obviously
to breath of the wild for the combined
main + side plus shrine slash shrine
quests number that far out does Ocarina
of times total so point number 4 breadth
of the wild hands-down argument five
items slash abilities so this one is
kind of hard to at first it may seem
that it's also obvious because of the
many different weapons in breadth of the
wild each with different charged attacks
the different armor sets and the total
of four special abilities you get in the
game and that's partially true but let's
not forget the hookshot or the iron
boots and oh I don't know underwater
exploration and the unbreaking heroes
bow and mash
sword oh and the ocarina of time and the
three goddess inspired powers you get in
the game and that's what makes this a
closer argument than one would think
however the initial point still stands
even though the hero of wild doesn't
have all the gadgets the hero of time
used he still has the singular sheikah
tablet and all those really fun and
creatively intuitive abilities like
controlling metallic objects creating
ice platforms anywhere water is present
and stopping the flow of time
temporarily on an object oh and square
bombs so that combined with the many
different weapons and armor sets and
bonus effects and four special abilities
gives this fifth point to breath the
wild rather soundly argument six
dungeons without having to create
another spoiler warning I'm going to
touch on this subject as someone who has
completed all dungeons of both games
without any online help as is my
tradition the first time through a Zelda
installment I did enjoy the dungeons of
breadth of the wild and now I'm not
talking about the shrines yes I have
completed all 120 of them those have
already been given towards breadth of
the wilds questing point I'm talking
about the four dungeons that once
completed actually changed the ending of
the game they were short honestly almost
disappointingly short although I will
admit this provided no chance for me to
tire of the dungeon I was in for even a
little bit but it's almost like I wanted
that from breath of the wild I wanted
the dungeons that were quote as big as
Hyrule Field from ocarina of time end
quote which I've been expecting since
Nintendo today published this article
back in 2014 saying just that but sorry
to disappoint anyone else who was also
wanting that the dungeons can each be
completed in a rather quick setting
taking up a mere 15 to 20 minutes of
your time at the most over a nice cup of
tea there's four of those that's it now
I don't have to go over Ocarina of times
eight dungeons in detail but each one on
your first time through most likely
takes at least an hour to complete while
the setting music story characters and
items you use and obtain as rewards set
the dungeon in a special place in your
memory permanently there is build up to
each dungeon and breadth of the wild but
it is nowhere near as calculated or
impactful as Ocarina of times heck the
shadow temple in awkward
time requires you to complete a mini
temple as a child before you even have a
chance to enter the actual shadow temple
the spirit temple consists of completing
half of it in the past and half of it in
the future and overall Ocarina of times
dungeons were just more impactful and
challenging and unique hands down so
point number six goes to ocarina of time
all right
before the seventh and final point let's
look at the score so far well holy for
RA we have a so far at high of three to
three
this final seventh point will determine
the winner of the gaming showdown of the
century
are you ready of course you are so let's
go argument number seven the final point
impact which game has had more impact to
the Zelda community or the gaming
community as a whole a better question
would be how does one determine this
well I'm very glad that you asked me
that to determine the impact of a video
game simply requires one ingredient time
and not an ocarina either I'm talking
about in the years to come we can then
fully judge which game left more of a
burn in our memory more of an impact in
our cell dividing hearts more nostalgia
for a new treasure but wait I just
remembered we don't have that ingredient
not for breadth of the wild so so I
can't determine who gets this point
because breath of the wild hasn't had
nearly the amount of time Ocarina of
Time has and therefore I can't determine
a winner why in the world would you do
this to us math Nintendo banned it
well quite frankly because it's fun and
because I have an idea on how to
determine the winner based upon impact
point seven goes to you it's your point
and the game you give it to is the
winner of the gaming showdown of the
century no pressure so that's it guys
that's the entire argument piece by
piece and as detailed of a measure as I
could go in a reasonably timed video of
course which game is better hey you tell
me one thing I do know is that both
games will forever be two of my most
cherished and favorite video games of
all time
I along with you
or to the next installment Nintendo will
unveil to us eventually because if it
keeps going this way there's going to be
a much greater gaming showdown to come
anyway hey thanks for watching if you
liked this video and you want to see
more stay tuned to mass Nintendo Banat
by clicking the light button and the
subscribe button I have another video in
the works about the relation between
Ganon and Ganondorf coming soon so until
that next video my friends keep playing
Zelda Mass Nintendo ban it out please